good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
yesterday I had one of my teeth
forcefully removed from my skull and I'm
in a lot of pain and frankly kind of in
a bad what what am I in an airport I'm
gonna throw this out if you've boarded
all customers than why why do you need
to brag on it protip never make a video
about how you're not going to be in an
airport for six months because then the
fates will conspire against you so in
addition to being in considerable
physical pain Hank there is also the
psychic pain of being in an airport
unexpectedly I'm on my way to Los
Angeles to do things but Hank let us not
dwell on our various miseries instead
let's discuss advertising I think I
realize that you and I are like the only
two people in nerdfighteria who are
bothered by advertising but I'm still
bothered by it so I'm just gonna make
this video for you I guess now it's not
like I'm inherently bothered by like
corporate sponsorship of art or whatever
here's what bothers me
imagine you watch a one-minute video of
an adorable kitten riding a Roomba and
then you watch a 1 minute video of
minutephysics explaining like special
relativity or something the advertisers
on both those videos care who you as the
viewer are like they care about how old
you are and how much money you make they
probably care about what your favorite
pony is who your favorite Pony is I hope
I didn't just alienate the entire brony
community by calling ponies once said
anyway the advertisers don't really care
about the difference between a kitten on
a Roomba and minutephysics what they
want is for you to lean back and enjoy
content so that you are also leaning
back and enjoying yourself when you
watch their ad you hear this all the
time when you talk to television people
they're constantly bragging about how
they make Leanback entertainment now
it's true that there are a lot of
excellent shows on television although
most of them are on cable which is
funded partly by like crowdsourcing but
I would argue it's no coincidence that
the TV shows with the strongest
communities right now are not funded by
advertisers I'm looking at you Doctor
Who and also you mr. handsome batch so
Hank to me the problem with advertising
is that it doesn't incentivize the best
views it incentivizes the most views it
says what's ultimately valuable about
YouTube communities is not their
passions or their achievements but just
their sizes like back in 2007 Hank when
we only had a few hundred regular
viewers the nerdfighter community was
still doing really interesting stuff
together nerdfighters made their first
thousand dollars in Kiva loans when we
had fewer than a hundred subscribers so
how do you make projects that are
interesting and important but don't get
a million views a video sustainable okay
so in the comments here last video I
basically saw 5 mod
one the paywall you know you don't get
to watch a video and lesson until you've
paid to be a member my problem with the
paywall is that I don't think it
strengthens a community to have it
consists entirely of people who can
afford to pay to watch stuff option two
Kickstarter in kick-starting and
probably call it kick starting
Kickstarter is awesome but it mostly
makes sense for something that has an
end you know like a movie or an album or
a game something that you will make and
then ship you can't really have a
Kickstarter for a YouTube channel
because hopefully it will last like
forever no I'm not probably not forever
forever is an incorrect concept option 3
everybody volunteers so the budget is
zero I like this option is basically
what we did with Brotherhood 2.0 but
it's often impractical the thing is
people particularly proper grown-up
people like myself who sit around in
airports pointing cameras themselves
making everyone around them
uncomfortable like to eat and pay rent
and stuff option 4 sell merchandise so
people can support the thing they love
while also bragging about the thing they
love and that's a good idea speaking of
which brain scoop merchandise I have no
involvement with the brain scoop by the
way except loving it and then there's
option 5 the public radio model Public
Radio has fundraising campaigns they
have membership options where you can
donate like $3 a month or whatever they
also get some money from corporate
underwriting they sell an ass-ton of
tote bags and then they also get some
grant money and some public money and
short the money comes from many
different places they don't require
listeners to give but they ask listeners
to give and then they explain where that
money will go and I at least I'm always
happy to be a member of my public radio
station even though I understand that I
don't have to be a member in order to
listen Hank the truth at least for me is
that if I'm part of a community that I
really value I'm not gonna support it
because I get like secret perks that
aren't available to other people I'm
gonna support it because I like it and I
want it to grow and thrive
whether it's say Frank or wheezy waiter
or Hannah Hart or the South African
nerdfighter s sandy Ozzie I want to find
a way to say thank you for making me
lean forward and I just don't think
advertising alone can do that all right
I got to get on my plane hegh dftba I'll
see you on Friday